that that Korean spa is there's things
going on like spa I don't even know and
eat Pauly Shore goes there mm-hmm
and one day does did what's up with the
the vans outside and so next to the
[ __ ] spa is a sushi place that's
never opened and at 2:00 in the morning
girls will just walk out of there and go
into these vans and they'll drive away
everywhere in Koreatown I what I once
had a birthday at a karaoke spot and
half of the place was strictly for
karaoke and half of the place were
full-on orgies yeah so if you if you
walk into the karaoke spot there's a
middle a censor bar there if you're a
girl sitting in that center bar you're
basically you're you're an escort and
the reason I found this out it was the
hard way was because I was a little
tipsy humor that plate and I walked into
the wrong room and they were full like
four grown like businessmen type Korean
men with women like it was a full-on
gangbang and three of my other friends
accidentally went into that room too and
we kept going and like like we'd [ __ ]
learn the first time we were also just
really curious and a lot of these places
in Korea sound especially when they
don't have like an English sign to them
I'm not trying to like incriminate
people but yeah usually it's just what
happens in LA you know but I was there
when Polly asked the owner about it oh
so he we walk up to the owner and all
because so the guy that owns the Korean
spa this old Korean dude who he has my
me and a baseball players headshot
hanging from this spot in the in the in
the cover booth okay right because he
used to watch Mad TV late at night and
also side note I'm not even kidding you
and ask Paul II asked my brother the
biggest dick I've ever [ __ ] seen and
not for being Asian he's got a bigger
dick than black people whoa
I mean this thing is like it goes to his
need
wait soft soft [ __ ]
no he did something but cement in it
what your skin can absorb some medical
so anyway so Polly goes up to the owner
and goes dude what's that and he goes so
the ladies and stuff coming in and out
how does that work and this is what he
said no and that's always that so you
know what's up no I mean it's like what
he can't we can't even ask a question
when I first started dating Bobby and I
still do this now every time he says
he's going to the spa I've always liked
my reaction as always okay like have fun
the spa when I first start dating him
the assumption was that there was it was
taking you there yeah I've never seen
things wrong during the data upstairs
the second day let's play ping pong itis
yeah it's actually like I I swear to God
on my parents life that I've never done
don't know what the [ __ ] okay I go there
for the spa no I believe that but I just
I know but I don't like a hard line if I
really want some shin that you think
that I'm getting like side [ __ ] there
yeah it's not permeable it's not promote
[ __ ] is not permeable yeah I don't do
that I believe you but I've also seen
gang wars there I was there with the Mel
k-town Mel Rodriguez Aaron caterer who's
a stand-up Nelson actor he's on that HBO
nursing show I don't fit stuff get on oh
whatever that was with Alex Borstein
anyway I was there with Mel we're
sitting there on the bench like these
park benches 2:00 in the morning and
then all of a sudden 12 cars just come
into the parking lot people just walk
out of the cars with sticks and bats and
they have a full-blown fight it was
incredible
it was like Tokyo Drift holy [ __ ] but
just sticks and bats aw yeah ice cream
ah if there was
guns I would have left Asia don't do
that [ __ ] we don't do we know we when we
kill creations we want to see your eyes
weapon we do weapons
we're not [ __ ] from afar we dig a
[ __ ] tailpipe into your [ __ ]
culture
oh Jesus okay but yeah so that place is
magical and I'm not gonna tell you what
it's called I mean it's named it said it
we've said it in previous parts but
we're not I don't want anyone to go
there we may have said it you know
there's lots of them in LA that's just
it oh yeah there's lots of them in LA
right now I got a weak spot personally
but yeah but that's for the main street
it's for the mainstream no that's the
thing I don't like I don't like you know
the people go wonder you play The Comedy
Store and not the Laugh Factory
but the Comedy Store is gritty it's
there's this element of danger there and
that's what I prefer same with the spot
that I go to there's an element of
something not not there's not something
wrong something's wrong something's not
right
yeah but I like it mm-hmm I could die I
like that feeling naked we dope all over
your body
we're Blom I got how sad would that be
that's how I got it so you just like
this yeah and then like the ambulance
comes and I'm just literally cover it
covered so naked covered in 800 that'd
be so funny
Bobby Lee dies with soap all over his
body I could get that much so far
[Music]